all right Joe uh where are you from
originally where'd you grow up Brooklyn
New York born and raised
you're a Brooklyn boy yes sir tell me
about how you grew up we grew up in a
tough Italian family old school mother
made sure that you know we had
everything that we need and my father
went out to work basically my father
wanted my mother to stay home while he
worked my father had a crazy life
growing up also my father you know he
worked for certain people in the
neighborhood if you know I mean certain
people
you know doing jobs you know collecting
for certain people if they didn't have
their pay my father would have to get a
little nasty with them like you know
kick their ass and stuff like that just
to make do for the family
and stuff like that and my mother my
mother knew what the deal was but my
mother cut them out shut because you
know my mother knew he was a living
also you know and my father used to take
you know my father would come home with
money after money and money we never
asked questions my mother never asked
questions it's just that my father was
hey let's go out let's take a ride
somewhere let's go to Coney Island let's
go here here
without asking any questions about it
and you know my mother was grateful for
that and like my mother my mother's like
I said my mother was very old school so
my father was very old school
and my father was a jersey man and my my
mother met my father
in the city where she came into the city
New York and my father would be a
bouncer because my mother would be with
her girlfriend to watch they would go
watch wrestling events and they were my
father would be at this hotel where the
wrestlers would stay and my father would
be the bouncer downstairs and my mother
would walk in every month because that's
when they would have the shows and she
met my father today my father would be
like hey why do you why are you dealing
with these phonies for my mother's like
well entertainers my father goes I'm a
real man why don't you come with a guy
like me so my mother left and you know
she took it you know bluntly but then
all of a sudden she's seen how my father
was this tough guy but my mother liked
that toughness of a person like that
and so
I started dating and stuff like that my
father was a lot older than my mother I
I say about 15 years older than my
mother
and basically you know then I popped out
and my father you know I was just my
father spoiled me you know growing up
with my father was like oh my God like
it's like Dad can I have that before I
even said it my father I've always had
whatever I wanted because my father
had really you know my father had it and
basically growing up with my dad
was like I tell you it's like you know
you had these guys we'd be sitting at
the table these big goons were coming to
the house with suits on and you'd be
like Mom who are these guys she'll be
like
Joe when you get older you realize who
they are and it's like these guys were
like
big ugly dudes and you'd be like and I
was like Mom who are these guys like son
you when you get older you realize it
that's how basically when I got older
and I saw you know you start watching
these movies and you you see the same
stuff that was going on in the movies
then he started picking up Mom the dad
was daddy in the you know the you know
whatever and then my mother said yes yes
yes you know you got to keep your mouth
shut keep this back in there you always
kept your mouth shut you never saw your
friends you never said any but your
friends knew and your friends were like
your best friends because they knew your
father was doing something basically
in the community you know and all that
stuff like that but that was that was my
father it's an interesting childhood
very interesting yeah how far are you in
school
how far I went to school I dropped that
attention I went to I dropped out of
10th grade to go to work because my
father passed away when I was in 10th
Grade so I was basically about 14 years
old and I just started
you know work I was I started doing you
know odd jobs here working for the guys
in the neighborhood you know doing these
delivery stops and stuff like that take
this over there take that over there
never tell my mother
so my mother's one day goes into my
drawer and she sees a big bankrupt she
goes
Joe you make more money than I do what
are you doing so I would be like Mom I'm
working for these guys but she was she
got very mad at me but then she
understood
you want to be like your dad I'm like
basically yes that my dad was like my
idol my dad was forget it my dad meant a
lot to me
growing up and stuff like that
and my dad was oh my God my God I could
describe my dad as
tough like nails I remember one time
there was like there was a thing where
there was no trucks allowed on the Block
and my father would do these roadblocks
where there's no trucks allowed on the
Block and my father took a baseball bat
to this guy's truck and I was like what
the hell's going on here
so then I knew how tough my followers My
Father didn't give a [__] about anything
my father my father bullets could fly
off his chest he didn't give a [__] as
long as his family
was full and he slept good at night and
they had furniture and they had a roof
over the head
and that was basically it that's you
know and that's how I decided I wanted
to be like my dad and that's what I did
when I dropped out of 10th grade I
started doing these odd jobs
what kind of careers have you had you
had different jobs through the years
right basically when I was when I first
started like I said I started doing
I started doing these little collections
for these guys in the neighborhood and
you know until I got older I started
doing bigger jobs and neighborhood and
it was basically like a debt collector
kind of thing and then
and then to me I was always then all of
a sudden I you know I was always a big
fan of professional wrestling that was
my biggest thing because my mother my
family used to watch it all the time
and I said wow I like that people get
beat up and that was my thing in the
streets get you know fighting every
night fighting every day and my mother
would be watching this thing and I was
like Mom I want to do that she's like
you want to wrestle I'm like that's
that's what that is wrestling she was
yeah so I would watch it every time I
say that's what I want to do for a
living until one day I want you in a
wrestling event and I see these two guys
wrestling now see but I see them talking
before the event is on I'm like wait a
minute is this real Faith then I
realized my mother told me to deal
I said I want to do that
so I said all right so then I I was on
the agent now I'm hitting the age of 16
I went to a school and they they was
teaching you how to wrestle and that's
what I did and I started I became a
wrestler and I've been wrestling for 23
years
and and
basically what I did in wrestling I went
into the ring not for the phony expert I
wanted hearing to hurt people
where I know where I can't get locked up
and that was the best thing that
protected me when I'm entering I beat up
people we're actually going to get
locked up I took my anger out of people
when I took them when I was home I took
my anger out I went to the ring and I
took my anger out of people and that was
one of my jobs I did and also I did I
was a bounty hunter and I you know went
to go out and I collected bounties for
these agencies where if they uh if they
borrowed money from
the guy I worked for it's like basically
being a debt collector but you're going
but you're working
legally you're going to the people
and you're going to collect that bounty
so my boss the bondsman wouldn't
be able to lose his money will you be
able to go get that money for him get
these people put them behind bars before
they escape
that's what you do and that was
basically my two jobs I did and then
later on in life I got into more crazier
jobs in life and that's what I did what
kind of crazy other jobs do you have
bouncing bouncing that's my present job
right now that's what I do I'm about
I've been a bouncer for 25 years you
know basically when I was doing
everything
from the wrestling
uh bounty hunting and doing the
collections I became a bouncer at the
end so also it's about
the physical ability so it's all the
same skill set for all these basically
yes it is yes it is but you know but now
these days
if you if you take somebody your own way
they got you know they got the cameras
out they got they're taking pictures of
you and it's and for me it's not hard to
say hey he did it the way I look these
days
and yeah
I just got to be careful about working
The Nightlife for over 25 years you know
sometimes it gets to you you gotta be a
good days and you have your bad days
I'm sure you have some great stories oh
my God I got some crazy weird stories
you know back in the day was okay
because I would like back in the day
where we had a different crowd not like
the crowds we have now I would wear the
same bloody t-shirt thank God it was
black bloody t-shirt because I knew it
was going to be a fight that night I
would wear the same shirt every night
because tonight was gonna be a fight
tomorrow's gonna be a fight it was like
watching that movie Roadhouse but it was
a lot worse because it was Brooklyn a
lot worser
than it than the movies when people
understand how bouncing is easy you sit
there all day but when a fight comes I
want to see if somebody jump up in the
ass start fighting you you're sitting
there all those hours it's easy
but no it's not it's like what they say
in a porn business pawn shop you don't
know what's coming through that door
until you get it believe me
you're dealing with the crazy people
drunk people crazy I call them Misfits
and morons that's what that was that's
my saying Misfits in morons I deal with
because they come in
first thing they want to do is they they
it's always a little guy they try to
size you out they look at you they look
at you and they're the one you know
array it's gonna stop with you because
they want to see how good you are let's
see if you can get it on but let me tell
you something I respect those little
guys because those little guys are
tougher than those big guys and I tell
you it's the truth I've seen little guys
knock out guys bigger than me and it's
crazy
but I know how to handle I know how to
handle it because I've been doing it for
so long and you know I did special
training for law enforcement and plus
also
I was a professional wrestler so I know
how to restrain people
basically is there something what what
is it but certain men not all men but
some men just thrive on being tough
being they come in they want to show off
because we're kind of like a business I
work in I work in a gentlemen's club so
basically it's the women that are
dancing it's the topless joint so women
the guys you're going to come and you
want to show up because the girls are
there they're dancing and the guys want
to be macho
but when you know when they come through
that door they're going to see me I'm
like a roadblock I make sure when you
come through that door you're going to
see me and you're going to know who I am
first you know I'm not going to be an
[__]
but also I want respect the way I'm
going to give you that respect when
you're coming to the door I want respect
back because that's how this game is you
know and basically if I see you doing
something wrong I'm gonna come up and
I'm gonna say Hey you know I'm gonna
give you I'm gonna give you one warning
that's what I'm going to give you
usually I told you I throw your ass out
the [__] door with the door closed
once I hear somebody's Hey Hey Joe you
know blah blah blah I'm gonna come at
you
you know and I I'll take care of you
I'll take you Dad I'll walk you to that
door peacefully
but let me tell you something that arm
comes up and you swing at me I guarantee
you you're not gonna wake up the next
day
I tell you I tell you that
who's the toughest person you've dealt
with
toughest person I dealt with eight guys
at once a long time ago these guys walk
into the club and basically they start a
little problem in there
and what happened was we had we took the
fight outside because you know you have
a lot more room on the outside
and basically I was stuck outside
you know by myself with these eight guys
and you know I was like okay you know
I'm not that my father always told me if
there's more guys there you fight dirty
you gotta do what you have to do and if
there's more guys there
so basically I'm fighting I'm punching
I'm feeling I feel I feel my hands wet
because I feel blood on my hands you
know I'm getting hit all over the place
you know and that all of a sudden I wait
I you know I turn around I see three
guys on the floor I was like oh okay wow
okay you know again that's you know two
guys are on top of me you know then the
cops came and they were like uh who did
this I'm like myself I did this myself
and people and the cops are like
[__] I'm like
look on the camera they seen the camera
you know this is my place this is I got
to support my family I'm not going to
make these guys walk into the place
where I work
to take the fool off my table and pay my
electricity and pay my rent for these
clowns like that to come in and try to
take it away from me no and I want them
to respect this place because without
this job
I can't live I can't eat I can't pay
rent I can't do this and to put a roof
on my family's head
without no job
but these guys came in when they knew
they they knew what they were going to
do when they came and I already see what
they were going to do because basically
I've been doing this for so long and I
knew when when you know when there's a
guy you're gonna come with the
experience I have I know what's going to
happen before they even know what's
going to happen
when they didn't even think about what's
going to happen I already know what's
going to happen
because I'm already a step ahead of them
because once they walk in they start
looking at the place they start looking
at they're still looking at cameras I
already know what they're going to do
which is when you first walk in a place
like that
and that's what happened to those guys
but they never came back after that
I wonder I mean do you
being a tough guy is part of your
personality it's just no it's your blood
being the tough guy I you know it's not
being a tough guy but you know what
I was always I was always a street
person I always I was always on when my
father died
I was me and my brothers were Street I
have two I had two brothers one passed
away
at age of 19 You Had a Brain Hemorrhage
so it was me and my me and my brother
you know me and my little brother
Anthony
but basically me and my brothers were
Street guys we knew what to do to
survive on the street so basically you
know being a street person you could
have Street smarts you want to know you
got to be two steps ahead of that other
person
so basically we were me and my brothers
we always fought in the streets they're
like oh you know Joe Mike and Anthony
yeah we know them that's the boys you
know that's the boys from the other side
of Brooklyn yeah we know who they are
well don't [__] with them you know you
know we already know about those guys
you know and like the people on the
Block when he always had a problem and
on the Block it would bring our Bell
just to help them out with a problem
because they already knew how we were
especially when it comes to Allah block
it was like me being in the club I'm
protecting the club
me I was born and raised on that block
for 47 years
so that's my block so we're going to
protect that block so that's why being a
tough guy is not being a tough guy
because then we tell you something
there's always a tougher guy above you
it's always a tougher person but of you
and uh being tough is just that it's not
it's not my person are you just being
being tough also is from being being a
professional wrestler playing the bad
guy in the ring Persona I guess that's
from being the tough guy but
my heart's so being tough was become a
because of my father would your dad be
proud of you now oh yes she would yeah
because number one number one he sees
that number one I'm protecting my family
he said always protect your family
always that's number one and number two
you got to protect yourself but your
family to him like people say protect
yourself first but my father was one I
gotta protect my family first then me
that's what my father always said and my
father was so damn proud you know my
father my father was 65 when he passed
away and I was 14. so my father showed
me a lot since I was you know being on
this Earth he showed me a lot
over the years you know since 14 years
you know he showed me a lot he showed my
brothers a lot too but not too much when
he passed Turkey my father was in and
out of uh
and out of jail basically when my second
brother was born because of stuff he was
doing so him and my middle brother
wasn't too you know he didn't know my
middle brother that much
but they got along of course but then
the baby came Anthony came he was always
home so Anthony was like my brother it
was like he was just pride and joy you
know and that was great but when your
first child comes out
the first child that was me it was like
the spoiled one the big one this is
going to be the one you know this is
going to be the one that's going to be
like me you know and I'm Junior so I
have to follow that you know senior
that's what he liked about it we never
had no sisters so my father was always
happy with the boys because he knew what
he could do with the boys
do you have any regrets in your life
regrets in my life
basically
not going not finishing school I think I
did not finish in school that was
probably it would be my regret in life
not finished in school it kind of sets
your life on a different path
by not finishing High School doesn't it
I think uh not finishing I think just
you know a lot I had a lot of time on my
hands also at that young age and you
know plus we're not my plus when I was
when I was doing these jobs when I was
doing these jobs for these guys I was
stuck to those guys I couldn't those
guys were like that's like my family
when they called me I had no choice to
leave my house and go there at a young
age I had no choice but then it was
getting to me at that young age where I
didn't want to do this but I had to but
I had no choice but they I already know
and they already knew I knew what they
knew so I had to do what they had what
they asked me to do so that's why I
regret I should have stated if I would
have stayed in but then also I said to
myself if I didn't stay in school how
would I help my mother out too
it was like I regreted not finishing
school
and then I regret it you know and then
not supporting now we're like I'm not
sure I'm not helping my mom out
it was like
like this for me it was like juggling
bottles you know but
but I managed I wanted to manage it was
there an opportunity to join in those
organized crime no basically when I
growing up you know you normally you
start learning more reading newspapers
knowing people that who got in trouble
knowing that
what happens you know what's the rules
and regulations and what's this and that
so that's when I started calming down
but basically they got you know the
people I worked for they're all gone now
they're all passed away well they're all
gone so
you know they took good care of me did
those families still those organizations
still exist
today date very low key they're very low
key you don't even see them anymore I
tell you back in the day you would see
them they would be sitting outside you
know with the with the friends you know
outside the clubs playing cards and
those were the guys you respect too
because they're protecting the
neighborhood you can walk past them
after one o'clock in the morning no
nothing happening to you that's what a
lot of people would say and it's the
truth but you don't see them anymore
because there's a lot of punks out there
I've got a lot of scumbags that right
away wannabes these young guys they want
to be in this life but then when they
get caught by the way they say oh he did
it he did it he did it and right away
because they can't face prison life
and prison I never like me myself never
stepped in never went to prison never I
was never in prison
I was always I always kept the straight
head I always knew what to do what to
say
you always got to keep your mouth shut
especially when you when you're in this
business you don't know nothing
and
you know and the cops you know if cops
knew and who was who in the neighborhood
they knew you know they you know I'm not
stupid they knew what I look like he
grew up in our street with tattoos on
your head whooping this walking that
they knew who you who you are who I was
so and I knew I wasn't a troublemaker I
didn't I was doing my job I wasn't
hurting nobody until a certain point
where
I started hurting people
and you know there's also like I said
it's a living you got to make there was
no at that time too a young age there
wasn't that many jobs and I wasn't
qualifying to work this it worked out I
was doing I was I worked on I worked on
I was a long shoresman I worked on a
Docs you know it's like it's like
watching a Rocky movie I was basically
the Lost Rocky or something like that I
worked I basically worked the docks
I uh I worked in a meat packing plant
not that I want to be Rocky Balboa no
but I worked I didn't meet packing
plants because they paid you know
picking up raw meat you know plus I had
to keep my body in shape too doing all
that stuff because I was always a
professional wrestler so what I was
doing now was I was basically
exercising my body making my body Strong
by lifting up raw meat put them on hooks
wrapping them up and working on the the
docks outside
again too you're picking up everything
you're doing this you're doing that just
keep my body straight just to keep my
body tough because I had no time being
in the gym because I had to work also so
basically well my my job was basically
picking up everything
boom and that was my weight training for
me until I you know went into the ring
and did my job but basically
like I was saying before about getting
into trouble and stuff like that like I
said I never been to jail they already
knew who I was
and that they knew I was in troublemaker
but when it came down to it when it had
to hurt somebody
to make my money to support my mother
too I had to I do whatever I can to
support my mother so when you were
collecting I was a killer yeah how how
do you go about getting what happened is
that
the person I work for
you know like they take bets and you
know basically you take a bet
like now the guy owes my boss money from
a bet or he borrowed money
you know and then they pay a vig and
stuff like that now you gotta go collect
that money now you know the time he says
I need that money by July 6th you know
July 6th you don't have that money I'm
coming for you
and they're going to give you oh my dog
my dog is sick my mother is in a
hospital for hemorrhoids I can't be with
my mother but they give you the line of
[__] they give you they give you
some line of [__] but then you have
to give them a little tape up a little
tape of his you're gonna give him a
little slap give him a little bruised up
so you know you know you did your job
but now the second time comes
now you're gonna have something broken
on you have a broken finger
now that's now there's now you don't
know the third plane is third plan is
that you're never going to walk again
that's the third plan
you have a choice
slapped up broken finger or don't wait
oh not walking anymore
that was my thing but you know I had to
support my mother
and to to take care of the legs you use
what what weapon
the worst thing you do is you pick up
you hurt somebody a piece of iron that's
the best thing you pick up a piece of
mind like a aluminum baseball bat I'll
do it
you break a knee just give them a little
sample just making them feel that pain a
human and I guarantee you and it
happened
then next day comes oh I got your money
I do I didn't have it your money's there
faster than I would tell the guy why
couldn't you do that soon you wouldn't
have to go through this why couldn't you
go through it sooner
but you know what that's life
that is life
well this is your what's been your
favorite memory my favorite memory
family Christmas time being with the
whole family Easter time because big
Italian tradition Sundays bigger Italian
dinner on the table macaroni gravy
meatballs sausage all that stuff with
the family holidays same thing just
being with the family that was my thing
being with the family
on holidays you had a big we had a big
giant table where 50 people at the table
now it's basically
me my wife
you know that's basically it you know
kids
my kids I tell you my kids are my cats
I'm a big let me tell you I have a big
heart and I don't call them animals to
meeting my children I call them the
children
my cats dogs cats raccoons whatever you
want to call
they are my children I have a big heart
for them and I will destroy somebody if
I see anybody hurt
the children
and I do my heart every day is I I make
10 stops a day and this is no [__] I
make 10 stops a day I feed Strays
outside every day
every day before I go to work every day
and I've read Strays and that's what I
do for a living that's my life that's
what I do for a living and I have no
problem
to feed the children because you know
the way we they got to eat too they
suffer because they're outside we don't
suffer they don't know how much love we
love them they don't know how much you
know they get hurt off a bit they get
hurt on the street they don't know how
much we love them but that's my heart
when if I melt for them but other than
that
I'm the biggest you know I'm the biggest
tough guy you would ever meet you got a
big heart I have a big heart also I'm a
big I also I'm a big tough guy too but
when it comes to them I melt when it
comes to them but I'll tell you one
thing
my wife she's has a big part of this too
she saved my life
a long time ago too because I you know
after I retired from professional
wrestling I blew up to 600 pounds and I
couldn't walk I couldn't do nothing we
were 600 pounds I was 606 pounds
couldn't do nothing I was just like in
the [__] I wouldn't be talking to you
right now Mark I won't be talking to me
I'll be in a [__] box
my wife just oh Joe we should go
maybe talk about surgery I would laugh
yeah yeah whatever
so one day I woke up I said you know
what let me get this surgery done
I wind up doing there you know I went
through there did this and there that
you know you had to go through the red
tape and stuff like that and they give
you this probation period you're gonna
give you six months you got to make sure
you do all their things before the
surgery comes I did it I lost over 315
pounds five years six years later I lost
215 pounds and I feel like I'm [__]
animal right now but you know little
things stop me here and there for a
little
ouch and edges from the beginning of
wrestling for so many years oh you have
your bad back you have your bad knees
but you know what you still got to go
with the flow but I feel a lot better
I'm stronger how old are you 47 years
old I'll be 48 next month still a young
man a young man I still have a lot to go
but I tell you what I would never be
able to I do I would never be hitting 50
I'd say that but
I think I'm going that way
but I wish I would never be able to hit
50.
that's how bad I've been and people
don't realize being 660 pounds it's like
being five people
it's like being five people it's a lot
of energy you have to spend just to get
it's a lot get around you know
but I pulled myself for a guy myself you
know you know being five foot eleven you
know
five five ten five eleven you know
having that weight you know you're
pulling it's like it's like pulling a
[__] car behind you you know it's
like seriously fooling it but you know
what I pulled a very strong pulling all
that weight yes I always notice I always
kept strong with my I always kept I
always kept myself physically strong
because from the years of wrestling you
know I always kept myself physically too
because the jobs I did also you always
got to keep yourself physical you know
when I was when I got sick I never told
nobody I was sick because you know you
know it's like having you know you have
a broken spoke on a tire the tire ain't
gonna go that well I never told nobody
Hey listen I was sick then they're gonna
say oh this guy's not going to be able
to work for us anymore I never said
nothing to nobody until that one day you
know I said you know I need some time
for myself to take care of myself and
you know then I then when I came back
three years later to my job and you know
unveiling myself the way I looked it was
like wow was that is that Joe
people's Tuesday like hey do you see the
guy with the tattoos and I said you
still work here because I've ever had
sometimes I played off I'm like no I
haven't seen 99 years because that's the
person you don't want to talk to because
you have your mouth he'll have your head
all day blah blah blah blah blah but
yeah so people know that's good when
people don't recognize you anymore
and you know you did something right but
other than that I feel great and I feel
strong like I said
the knees in the back hurts sometimes
but probably in their future being need
replacement but what's your greatest
strength
a greater strength
a greater strength would be
every two days it will be my wife and my
children my my cats that's my greatest
strength they give me strength
if my mother was here today which I I
wish she was I mean my mother was like
oh my God my mother was my best friend
and we my father was my best friend my
mother was here long my mother died
years ago she was 65 she was very young
and
and that story right there I wasn't when
I got sick and I was in the hospital she
got sick and she was in the hospital
also and it was hard because I did to
this day I did God took her and she and
she wanted me to stay down here to live
my life and she wanted you know she knew
she was sick she knew and she wanted me
to stay down here and she wanted to go
because it was a she was probably either
her or me so she chose to go and I I
still believe in that sometimes
she wanted me to be down here and live
my life
of all the different uh careers that
you've
been involved in what what was the
hairiest situation you've ever the area
situation
found yourself in
I tell you the hairy situation it wasn't
even in my jobs it was basically outside
my job basically it was basically
over a freaking parking spot that was
the best
you know you get these guys you know you
double block and they and you get these
guys they're gonna make it they can make
it make it through when you tell them
you can't make it you're driving you
know they're driving a freaking Mack
truck you know and they can't make it
and they have to and they of course they
hit your car
and that's that was like my hairiest
thing you know I I grabbed the guy you
know the worst thing I didn't even know
he had kids in the car
I dreaded I pulled the guy right out of
the car right out I think I was a tough
guy too because he was mouthing off but
he was mounted off behind of a window of
his car so I punched him I broke the
glass and this is no [__] it's like
watching a movie I pulled the guy right
out of the car and his wife was there
but I didn't know his kids were there
until I heard the kids crying but you
know
but you know what
he's going to learn but then his kids
are going to learn too never do that too
because look what happened to Daddy you
know but that that was the most hairiest
hairiest thing besides
I'm not gonna say it somebody pulled a
gun on me
when I was working in the club years ago
years and years and years ago
so my brother gone because I didn't let
him remember he had no ID this was some
another place I was working in just
about
25 years ago 30 years ago and the guy
pulled a guy putting onto my face
and you know what I said to the guy
again this is no [__] I said that he
got you pull it you pull it if not
what do you want to do we're going to
dance the guy was more shaken with that
gun in his hand than I was
because the guy seemed to face how I was
my face was glass my face was blue his
eyes my face was like like like
um a glacier my face was like
I said like red
you're going to pull the truth or aren't
you going once they hear that because
they expect you to be scared I wasn't
scared of that
I was not I was never scared because
like I always said you die you die
remember if God's gonna take you that
day he's going to take you but
the guy wind up running out but I but it
shows that I have I have the only fear I
have right now is basically losing my
family my family that that's my fear
losing my wife my children that's my
fearest that's that's the only fret
fighting wise for you beat up no it's
just that's my fear of losing my family
that's the most River I have in life
Joe what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life the most important lesson I learned
see
I'm going to give you the best the best
one I can give you
like my father always said to me
when you walk down the street
always look straight never look up
because when you look straight
that's where all the action that's where
everything is coming to you he goes once
you blink an eye you don't know what's
going to happen to you my lesson
increased one day you know when you look
you know these people right now they
have their cell phones on when they're
walking in the street they get hit by a
car me I felt like my lesson is you
always look straight in life basically
what I'm saying look straight in life
never blink and never close your eyes
because you'll know what you're gonna
miss in life also
keep your eyes open that's how I always
see it keep your eyes open because
keep your eyes closed like life right
now where you don't know what tomorrow
is going to bring
always keep your eyes open because you
don't want to miss that that big
surprise you're gonna get one day you
know that that was always my my lesson
it's my lesson it's just like keeping my
eyes open my father always told us
all right Joe thank you so much for
sharing your story
you're very welcome and it's my pleasure
I wish you lots of luck thank you so
much thank you